Here were the correct answers.
Doctor visits per year is an ordered data type, life expectancy is and
spending per person are both quantitative data types, and
has universal healthcare is a nominal data type.
Now among these four variables,
I think doctor visits per year was probably the hardest to identify.
Let's take a look at why.
Average number of doctor visits per year is represented by the size of
these circles.
And if we look closely we can see that each of these circles corresponds to
a range.
So basically we've taken quantitative data and
split it up into bins which makes this data type an ordered data type.
Average life expectancy at birth and spending per
person are both quantitative data types just like in the graph we saw before.
And whether or not
a country has health insurance is really just a nominal data type.
It's really a yes or no question.
So that's two categories